Weinstein surrender is the first time in
the first criminal case to arise from
the allegations by more than 80 women
Weinstein has repeatedly denied having
non-consensual sex with anyone CBS News
legal analyst Ricky clean men is here
with us also with us New York Times
correspondent and CBS News contributor
Jodi can turb Jodi co-wrote the first
story about allegations against
Weinstein Weinstein the reporting earned
a Pulitzer Prize and helped create a
worldwide reckoning on sexual harassment
and assault good morning good morning
Jodi what do you think this moment means
for the women that you've talked to over
the past year a tremendous amount and
not only from Harvey Weinstein's alleged
victims but really other women who have
been victims to Harvey Weinstein always
had his own private system of justice he
would hire private investigators he
would hi fans he would hire fancy
lawyers to settle allegations that it
turns out nobody knew about for years
and years afterwards there was an NYPD
inquiry into his behavior in 2015 that
mysteriously disappeared so this is kind
of the first time he's facing the same
justice system as the rest of us do you
have any idea Rickey about why it's
happening now there the allegations have
been so public many women have wondered
why hasn't he been brought to court
sooner do you have any thoughts on that
we hear you will be there today bail
will be set at 1 million dollars and
you'll have to wear an ankle bracelet
but why today finally do you think well
whether it's today next week or last
week the reality is this although we may
collectively believe because there are
80 women yes who have made allegations
against him that he may be guilty of
something and some heinous things that
it's a far cry from belief than it is to
having evidence that a prosecutor
believes he or she can prove beyond a
reasonable doubt side Vance the DA in
New York is very precise about when or
he will not indict and he believes that
you have to have the adequate quality
and quantity of proof
he eventually convened a grand jury they
have interviewed dozens if not hundreds
of witnesses they have gotten lots and
lots of documents and they were not
going to go forward with any of the
cases no matter how the rest of us may
have felt until they felt they were
ready and they're ready now what happens
now to him they go to court the
procedure in court is routine he will be
taking a mugshot and he will have prints
at the precinct goes to court set bail
you've talked about the bail package one
of the real questions is where is he
going to reside pending trial and then
the system starts conferences motions
and finally a trial or a plea Jodi I
want to go back to something you talked
about the system of justice that he
created for himself for escaping justice
what do you know about that network that
was around him that allowed all of this
to happen we seen him doing the perp
walk but what happened to the network
that allowed him to operate for so many
years well the network has largely
fallen apart because he had a system of
levers and favors and being able to work
the channels of power in New York and
Washington and Los Angeles and that's
gone now he's very isolated his lawyer
says he's very lonely and frustrated now
could he still use means to say settle
out charges privately with women to
evade further accountability yes that is
still possible but we should also say
this investigatory grand jury is still
working so we don't know if this is even
the last set of charges in New York City
and there are investigations in other
cities as well and might anybody who was
a part of that network who knew what
they were doing be in trouble in terms
of that grand jury that's a great
question and I think the other question
is will more women come forward now
because women feel more comfortable
coming forward when they know there will
be accountability and when they feel the
system works and so I'd like to know who
else is watching this clip right now and
saying maybe it's safe for me to tell my
story to the police does it's anything
Ricci that they're doing this so
publicly you know in many high-profile
cases you can make arrangements to be to
turn in it early in the morning or go
into a side door or something the fact
that this is so public do you think
they're sending a message here well
there was an agreement that had to be
reached between Ben Brafman and Harvey
Weinstein's attorney and the prosecutors
so yes there are times when you get it
done when in that picture I Ben was not
in that pic
he may be inside already or he may be
already at the courthouse but the
reality is that we know that the police
and the government do want to make a
public statement I don't think that we
would be truthful if we thought that
that was not so and we just saw it Jody
it has been I think 230 something days
since we've seen Harvey Weinstein and
since you're reporting first brought
forward these allegations
since then the me2 movement has has
ricocheted around the world and set off
a discussion about the systemic things
that take place that allow this behavior
to what's changed in that time today is
a great day to discuss that because we
know that social attitudes have changed
but the question today is how does the
law of the land respond this is the
beginning of that change
you know Thank You Joanne Jody thanks
Vicki can you see you